we're now living in a virtual world and
the UN Security Council the body in
charge of maintaining international
peace and security is not sitting in its
historic chamber in New York instead
ambassadors are operating remotely but
technically it's been far from smooth
yes we can
perhaps not unpredictably some are
forgetting to mute their microphones
when they're not speaking
[Music]
we need all mics closed please
sometimes meetings have had to be
interrupted because of technical issues
excuse me
I have a request the pause for us has
technical problems and Tunisia can't
hear very well and then resumed I want
to apologize for the technical
difficulty we have had today today's
conversation is especially important as
in the statement that's friend gave we
are the biggest problems have come in
connecting with the US ambassador Kelly
craft while other ambassadors have
stayed in New York she during the
pandemic has retreated to her home in
Kentucky and the connection has been
difficult in the end her deputy based in
New York had to read out her speech on
her behalf since the censer ambassador
was disconnected and has been unable to
reconnect to this system I will deliver
the remarks of the United States from
this point how happy is the UN with the
technology that it's providing to the
Security Council
if Technol if UN Security Council
members can't hear each other how are
they supposed to speak to the world we
are all trying our best to accommodate
the Security Council in all Member
States
and I we will continue to work through
whatever technical hitches they may they
may have been I will
would have to adjourn the session of the
meeting thank you
while all over the world meetings even
school lessons are taking place on
platforms like zoom the UN is using an
old conferencing system it's based in
Brindisi and Italy rather than here in
New York the Security Council represents
the entire international community but
for now it's technology does not seem
fit for purpose James BAE's al Jazeera
at the United Nations